on behalf of the office of executive
education here at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business
I'd like to welcome you to today's
webinar my name is Dina vanevski and I
will be your moderator today we will be
talking about how our nonverbal
behaviors affect our status and power
we've organized this webinar to give you
a taste of a Stanford executive
education experience today we're honored
to have with us professor grünfeld
professor Grunfeld is the Moga Dom
family professor of leadership and
organizational behavior she's a social
psychologist whose research and teaching
examined how people are transformed by
the organization's and social structures
in which they work her work not only
explains how power corrupts but also
suggests that it can be without
conscious awareness
professor Grunfeld is the author of
numerous articles on the psychology of
power and on group behavior her courses
received rave reviews from MBAs and
executives
she's also the co-director for the
executive program for women leaders
thanks for being here today
I'm going to talk with you about power
and share what I hope is a new
perspective and way of thinking about it
and what I'd like to do is start with an
observation which is that among the
people I work with one of the things
I've noticed is that when people are
preparing for a situation which they
want to have impact will have a tendency
to spend most of our time thinking about
what we're going to say and we'll worry
about how to make sure we sound like
we're better prepared than most people
will think about how to make the best
counter-argument to the challenges that
we receive we'll think about how to
present the best possible case for
whatever outcome we're trying to
advocate and there are a lot of good
reasons to do this and I'm I'm let's
take a look at what those are so I think
the ideas we have in our head about this
are the following first of all most of
us believe it's better to be right than
wrong so we start with that assumption
going into situations like this we
assume it's better to sound smart than
not
seems like a fair
assumption we so it's better to come off
competent and critical rather than
incompetent and easily misled and we
assume it's better to tell people
something they didn't already know so we
try to provide unique information that
moves the conversation forward rather
than to just repeat that to other people
what they've already said they seem like
perfectly appropriate beliefs and what
I'm about to tell you is that if you
look at the research on social science
we actually should not put as much
emphasis on these ideas as we think we
should so I want to talk first of all
just briefly about a couple books that
have really influenced my thinking in
this area the first one is the blue book
that you see on the screen which i think
of as kind of the grandfather of blinks
like so many of you have seen blink
what's this blue both judgment under
uncertainty told us when it was written
back in the 1970s is that in contrast to
the way that economists let's say think
about human behavior which is that they
tend to assume we're very rational and
careful in the way that we process
information
what Kahneman and Tversky showed in a
bunch of psychological experiments is
that if you really want to understand
how people make decisions what you need
to know is that they're not processing
information carefully at all so they
were the first psychologists really to
make the observation that we tend to
make decisions based on very small
amounts of information and we tend to
use kind of heuristics or rule of thumb
to make kind of quick judgments rather
than process information carefully for
those of you who have read blink what
you know is that Malcolm Gladwell made
the same type of argument but what he
was looking at specifically was how we
form impressions of other people and
what he described in his book was a lot
of really and interesting research some
of which has been done by psychologists
here at Stanford showing that when
people are trying to decide how good you
are how much respect they should give
you and how much power you should have
they're making those assessments very
very quickly often without any regard at
all for the quality of the arguments or
the things that you're trying to say so
one of the studies or programs of
research that Gladwell wrote about
book blink shows the following which is
that people will actually decide in a
kind of a gut level whether to give you
the thumbs up or the thumbs down in less
than 100 milliseconds so I think it's a
pretty powerful piece of evidence to
suggest that actually we need to
understand how people are making those
judgments and given the time the time
the small amount of time that it takes
to do this we have to accept the fact
that they're really not making these
judgments based on the quality of
information that we're sharing in
situations like this so judgments that
people make in less than 100
milliseconds have to do with trust so
these are the assessments that people
make very quickly about us in situations
where we show up and there are two
components of trust that are affected by
whatever signals it is that we're
sending people will decide very very
quickly how confident we are and people
will decide equally quickly whether they
can trust our motives in our character
so I think this begs are really
important questions we just need to know
how we do that how are we able to make
these kinds
judgments so quickly based on so so
little information right seems like
awareness of the information people are
paying attention to would be very useful
for us to know so let me just talk a
little bit about how to begin thinking
about this and then we'll look at it in
much more detail so if you look at
research that's tried to determine which
aspects of human behavior are the most
predictive of people's judgments of
other people you can look at the the
independence of three different factors
you can look at the impact of the words
you say you can look at the impact of
the way we use our voice and you could
look at the impact of the way we use our
bodies and what you'll see if you're
looking at the slide in front of you is
that the words account for typically in
research less than 10% of the variance
so people are making these critical
judgments about you based in large part
on the way we use our body physical cues
that were sending both in the way we
modulate and use our voices independent
of content and also in the ways that we
use we send off these very subtle
messages about our internal States
through the way that we use our bodies
how we hold ourselves the gestures we
use how we use our eyes and so forth so
there are two things about this that I
want to make sure you get the first one
is that this these data and data that I
showed you earlier suggest very clearly
that the vast majority of social meaning
comes from nonverbal behavior and the
nonverbal messages that we're sending
and in situations where our verbal and
nonverbal messages are not aligned what
people will remember what people take
away from the interaction is how we use
our bodies so this is something I think
we look need to look at with much
greater care so let's start with an
illustration I'm going to ask you to
look at an example and this is just a
way of showing how much actually we
already know about how different ways of
using our bodies affect the impressions
that we form of other people so what I
think you should see on your screen
right now is a picture of a person
walking
and it's a relatively impoverished image
right there just dots of light on the
vein joints in the human body and I've
just given you permission to form an
impression of this person based on very
little information so I'm just going to
ask you to consider while you're looking
at this what you know about this person
based on the way they're moving all
saying that they look purposeful okay
that's a mouthful sort of even movement
yes I think that's so that's something I
hear very often and the thing I would
ask you to consider as you're looking at
this is how do you know so what is it
about the movements in this figure that
looks purposeful to you it sounds like
one observation was that the that the
body was moving in an even way so I told
earth and older and then so the
shoulders are kind of still and the arms
are moving and it just it feels very
strong okay confident focused yeah
confident and focus are also words that
I hear a lot and I think it's great to
think about why that's true so even
movement I think is right part of what I
think you're seeing is that when a
person is focused and purposeful you
would assume that they're moving in a
deliberate and an even way so if the
clarity with regard to the energy coming
from their body in the direction in
which it's headed so one of the things
you can see from this is that if you
look at the way the body is moving most
of the movement is happening on one
plane so this person appears to be
walking toward you the legs are coming
forward the arms are swinging forward
there's very little movement on any
other planes there's very little
indication in the way this person's
moving that there's any thoughts in
their head about other directions they
could be pursuing right they seem to be
coming very clearly and purposefully
directly at you and I think that's right
I think that's right other observations
about this one um that they have sort of
a precise movement and someone suggested
maybe it's a male a guy because of the
way the hips are moving and the way the
hips are narrow so one of the first
things people will observe when I show
this is they'll say oh that's a man and
everybody nods their head yes that's
probably a man and then I think it's a
great
question to ask how we know that so
people often say well it's the hips then
I'll say well what about the hips so
some people say well it's the shoulder
to hip ratio some people will say it's
that the hips aren't moving very much
but my guess is we know this is a guy
well we don't really know how we know
it's a guy right I think that's really
interesting that there's something about
the way this consuming that's giving us
an indication of gender and it's so
implicit or so unconscious at some level
we're not really sure how that works
what I'd like to do is show you another
image to see if that helps did you have
another comment about this one someone
also said that the locked elbow
suggested determined and then they felt
that this was someone that they could
work with they were approachable okay
nice yeah so I saw the lost elbows
suggest that some type of determination
that's interesting and then this person
seems approachable or somewhat likable
and I think that's interesting to keep
in mind as we look at some of the other
images that I want to show you so let's
look at the second one if we can I have
another image okay so they should
provide a good contrast case and I'd
love to know what people's impressions
are of this person well the first thing
people said is they're definitely female
okay and they're sort of a snicker of
sort of just a very different approach
yeah a very different feeling when you
see that absolutely so normally when I
show this in a class people burst out
laughing clearly scenes female and again
I'm going to ask now if you can tell
what makes this way is moving more
female than the image that you looked at
earlier so there is a change in the
inner shoulder to help ratio I want it I
don't want to focus quite as much on
that because that's less about movement
and more about proportion but but I
think there's plenty here to talk about
what's moving we have a lot of people
sending in information I just want to
take a minute to just say that if you're
in a classroom with professor grünfeld
you would it would be a larger
discussion and everybody would be
participating and so you would have lots
of time to to get your ideas across I'm
just trying to throw out some of the
more common ones that I'm seeing people
say that the knees and fear closer
together yes yes
and I think that's right and does that
and and that's part of what makes it
look more female is that right so that's
uh huh I thought that was right I think
that's right and then someone else said
that there's a balance issue that it's
felt in the first one like the persimmon
tree balance and this one felt maybe
like they could be knocked over I think
that's absolutely right there we go yo I
think that's very interesting so so one
of the things you can ask yourself when
you're looking at this picture the first
thing people said about the first image
was that the person was very determined
and focused the confident was part of
that too I don't know whether the
confidence is undermined here but I
think this issue of balance is very
important so it may in fact undermine
the extent to which someone seems
committed to a particular course of
action or seems able to stay with their
position and on on objective and on goal
if their body seems more off-balance I
think you can ask yourself you know if
you think of this sort of in
evolutionary terms or caveman terms if
you had to move literally move someone
out of your way to get something done or
move someone off a position that they
had staked out it would be easier to
move this body than the other not just
because of the balance issue there is
movement on two planes now that's so
what we saw earlier was all pretty much
all the energy going once in one plane
here we have some energy moving forward
but there's also movement on a second
plane with the hips and to some extent
the arms and then there's the question
of whether having a more narrow base at
the bottom of the body suggests that it
that a person would be easier to throw
off balance and I think you know if we
think about this in modern terms of our
own interactions that may seem a little
bit contrived if you think about it in
terms of animal behavior or more
primitive context you can see how these
ways of using your body are actually
sending signals that invite or
discourage certain ways of approaching
discharge it I think that's right so we
a lot of comments on this one with it
the person seems a little bit less
determined yep and another is that they
seem bouncy or maybe a little bit more
useful okay
and let's see and also walking in heels
yeah so it's interesting how we impose
things onto this body that aren't
actually there but I agree people will
often observe that it looks like the
person's walking in heels which just
contributes to this idea of being easy
to topple over those of you who have
experience with heels know exactly what
I'm talking about one of the things that
I think creates that impression is that
this person stride is shorter than what
we saw earlier and when you're walking
in heels I think it's the the we're you
know wearing heels does tend to do that
to one stride but the other thing this
points out I want to make a you know a
big have a big emphasis on this because
it's one of the key things I wanted you
to see is that one of the main
differences between the first figure
that I show you and the second figure
has to do with how big of a footprint
this person is making with their body so
with the legs and the knees and feet
coming closer together you may also have
noticed that the arms and elbows are
moving slightly differently because
what's happening here is the elbows are
being held closer to the sides which is
what makes the arms have the appearance
of moving in a sideways direction the
female body is moving in a way that
creates a smaller footprint than the
male body was and the differences that
are associated with that are not just
about sex and gender they actually have
to do with power and status so if you
look at groups of men interacting with
one another or groups of women
interacting with one another what you'll
notice are these exact same differences
when you compare high ranking high
status high power members of those
groups and low ranking low status and
low power members of those groups so the
extent to which a person holds their
body in an expansive way takes up the
full space that their body is allowed
has a large footprint as opposed to a
small one is something that very clearly
associated with social rank with power
and status in humans and in animals and
the reason I'm going to suggest that
these differences show up in men versus
women is because women have lower status
than men in society so
little girls are not born walking like
this alright these are patterns of using
our bodies that we learn over time from
people who care about us and want us to
be successful in social life part of
what's necessary to be successful is to
be able to indicate through your body
language that you know your place so men
and women tend to be socialized to
either but use their bodies in different
ways and expansiveness both
expansiveness and this idea of moving
all on one plane are associated with the
way boys and girls moods you learn to
use their bodies and men and women let
me show you one third one third figure
one example just to give you the other
end of the spectrum we had just one more
thing oh yeah the last one was it as it
appeared the person was less driven yes
which I thought was I think that's right
I think that's right I think all that
you imply you you infer all those things
from the extent to which a person's
energy seems to be channeled into their
body in a way that's propelling it
forward in a unit in in a you know
unitary or unified direction I think all
those observations are right on target I
we have a bunch more do you want me to
start giving you ones for this one and
that welcome back to a service one and
really I'm just a little concerned
because you can spend hours on this
actually I don't want to take up much
time for so many things I want to cover
I just want to illustrate for you some
of the things you already know about
this actually so there are there are
things we know with certainty about the
meaning of the ways that we use our body
and we're often not aware of it so this
is what I want to just put a sort of a
finer point on I want to talk about this
other end of the spectrum because this
is really important and I think helps
with understanding the meaning of these
ways of holding our bodies and shows
sort of the other the other polar
extreme so what you're seeing here gasps
is that this person looks less
approachable for sure than the first one
so this is a clearly a male image but
this is a person you don't want to mess
with right this is not someone who
you're going to cross and I think it's
very interesting to look at how the body
has changed here so I talked about the
dimension of expansiveness that was one
you'll notice that the knees and feet
are even wider so the stance underneath
so the body is even broader in this
particular range angry and focused
strong yet strong so it's interesting
that the knees and feet are further
apart the elbows are way away from the
body now and what I think is really
interesting again if you see strength
you see anger and strength in this image
but remember we're just projecting that
on to this image based on how it's being
held and how it's moving we see muscle
mass here that's not actually there
because of the way the body is being
held right if you have giant muscles in
your upper and lower body you can't have
your limbs very close to your torso and
when you look in the animal kingdom at
high-ranking animals who need to remind
lower ranking animals who's in charge
this is exactly how they use their
bodies and you see the same thing in
human behavior as well this particular
way of standing the expansiveness is
somewhat extreme here you'll also notice
that relative to the previous image the
one that was more female this body seems
to be moving almost entirely in one
piece so the body is almost like a
fortress
here a little bit less relaxed a little
bit less approachable than the first
male image that we saw and these ways of
holding the body are very clearly
associated with Authority and
authoritative nough so actually if you
look at the way people are socialized
into officer ranks in the military and
police force what you'll see is that
they learn to hold these hold their
bodies in these ways so think about the
last time you got pulled over for
speeding this is how the police officer
shows up picture at your window right
very quick communication just remember
who has power and situation who has the
gun who has the law on their side and
what it does the positive effect of it
is that it reduces the chances of
conflict between the high and low
ranking person which is the reason these
signals and ways of using our body are
so important for maintaining harmony and
good relationships among people within
various types of groups anything you
want to add on this Pam well we had a
few people who said that it seems as
though they're strong
don't see smart anymore oh yeah this
person they're definitely lost a few IQ
points and I don't know exactly how to
explain that except to say that there is
this idea that we have I think in our
heads between the kind of mental focus
and mental process that's necessary to
dominate someone and we have this idea I
think when knowledge or understanding of
what happens to our mental capacity when
we get angry so when someone has to pull
all their energy into preparing for a
physical fight there's a lot less energy
there's a lot less going on inside the
head and that's part of I think why you
see a reduction in IQ points in this
particular person we had a lot more
questions on this but I think the one
that I'd like to pose is on how Hite
plays into the invasion sure so it's a
really important question and in the
research of social science on predictors
of power and Status and groups Hite has
a huge impact that won't surprise you
given what I'm saying it doesn't mean
that you have to be the biggest person
in order to have status and power and
sandwich I think turns out to be much
more important is the way you hold
yourself and the footprint you give
yourself given the actual space that
your body takes up so I think that's an
important thing for people to know who
are who are I don't know what the
expressions but challenged in in terms
of how tall they actually are the other
thing is that you know people know this
too is if you feel disadvantaged by your
height it's you know can be useful to
think about orchestrating meetings where
you're sitting and also to make sure
that in physical confrontations you
maintain enough space where the visual
perspective makes you seem makes the
height differential seem seem smaller on
the cam so what I wanted to illustrate
with these and I think I'm finished with
these now what I wanted to illustrate
with these is how much you already know
about this I think it's you know very
amazing to people when they don't think
about it and how much they actually know
and how much they're reading off
people's bodies on an everyday basis I
wanted you to realize that there is very
clearly a body language of power and
status and we all know it but we know it
so well we don't know it
something we've been learning from a
very very young age and I want to make
the suggestion today that I believe very
small subtle physical changes can have a
huge effect not only on how people
perceive you the extent to which they're
prepared to to give you status and power
in group situations but the way we hold
our bodies in very subtle changes in the
way we hold our bodies really affect our
own psychology and how powerfully we
actually show up in situations like this
so let's take a look at that I want to
make the suggestion if you if you wanted
to think about how to use your body in a
way that was sort of strategic in terms
of trying to maximize the likelihood of
attaining a high rank in the groups
where you operate there are really two
things that we all need to be able to do
we need to be able to show up
authoritative on the one hand when a
situation calls for it and we need to be
able to show up approachable when a
situation calls for it as well let me
just say a few words about what I mean
by these things and talk about the body
language implications so when we're
trying to show up authoritative part of
what you need to understand is just the
nature of the bees is that authoritative
nough psychological distance between
yourself and other people so what you're
doing when you're acting authoritative
is your privilege and experience over
the knowledge and experience of other
people that's what it means to have
authority right you've decided that you
know better and this creates space
between people right so there are a
couple different ways you can do this in
terms of body language I want to show
you what those look like in just a
moment but in the discipline that I've
been working with in my courses drawing
on interactions that I have in
collaborations with people in the
theater who work on acting and how
actors show up with power is that the
body language associated with
authoritative this is called playing
high and I'm going to show you what that
looks like in just a moment we all need
to be able to do that when a situation
calls for it at the same time we need to
be able to show up approachable it's an
equally important skill set some people
think when approaching this content area
that playing high is what they need more
to more of and that be more
authoritative is going to give them more
power I think that's not a conclusion
you should jump to at all
what you need to understand is that both
being authoritative and being
approachable are tremendous sources of
power and those who you for whom
approachability is your superpower know
this is true you need to be fluent you
need to be able to adjust your
psychological orientation and your
physical orientation into roles and
situations that require but these just
different aspects require these
different aspects of behavior on the
approachability side what we're going to
do where Authority Authority tunis
requires putting psychological distance
between yourself and other people on the
approachability side you're trying to
reduce psychological distance right what
you're trying to do is to put our
people's knowledge and experience on the
same plane on the same value level as
your own there are a lot of different
ways you can do this I'll show you what
they look like in just a moment but the
physical actions associated with being
approachable are called playing low in
this discipline that I want to share
with you it comes from work by Keith
John's own for those of you who want to
read more about this who is a British
theatre director and has written about
this extensively in some of his books
these two aspects of behavior I think
are things that most of us know if we've
ever worked in in organisations we know
these are two critical elements of
leadership and effective management
what's really interesting about thinking
about these two objectives from the
point of view of body language is that
you can see and you'll see very clearly
that you cannot be both of these things
at the same time the psychological
orientation and physical orientation of
authoritative miss is incompatible with
the psychological and physical
orientation of approachability and I
think a mistake that a lot of us make is
understanding we need to be both
authoritative and like bowl or
approachable at the same time as we try
to be both all the time and in that case
we're neither were not believable in
either type of situation what I tell
people is what people from the theater
would tell an actor which is to say the
way to handle these different objectives
is to go into a situation try to read
what's called for from you given your
rank in the group that you're in and
commit when authoritative this is called
for it may be five seconds it may be 10
seconds you
step into that without hesitation
without apology and when approachability
is called for you don't try to hold on
to those last vestiges of power and
authority because you're afraid people
are going to run away with it right you
have to make the commitment and fully go
into one or the other of these different
orientations so let's take a look at
what those look like actually these
lists I said before very important for
me to tell you are not management
prescriptions by any stretch of the
imagination you'll see what I'm talking
about in just a moment these are
descriptions from a British theatre
director whose job is to Train actors
and directors in the discipline of
status in the discipline of being able
to get into high and low status
characters and high and low status roles
these are people who are very very
astute observers of natural human
behavior and they learn to use their
bodies to show up authentically these
different ways so John Sloan has
described what it looks like to play hi
what playing hi which behaviors are
associated with authoritative naissance
test in a theatre so I'll just go
through this list quickly with you you
hold your head perfectly still while
talking you speak in complete sentences
so when playing hi they're not to be
long sentences in fact it's better if
they're short but when playing high your
sentence will have a very clear
beginning and a very clear endpoint you
hold eye contact while addressing other
people and an important caveat to this
that comes from the social science
literature is that in a high status
person what you'll see is holding eye
contact slightly longer than normal when
addressing someone that's sort of a
tactic of intimidation that some people
have seen use but when being addressed
by a lower ranking person the high
status person is free to look away so
it's a kind of an ace and asymmetry in
the way that you use gaze in these types
of situations you move smoothly right so
we observe that in in the in the dots of
light illustration I showed before in
playing hi you occupy maximum space lean
back
slow down
and make great sweeping gestures to let
your space flow into others let me just
say a little about this these may
surprise some of you the Leanback
slowdown aspects in particular I think
are not what people often associate with
acting in a powerful way but if you
think about what it means to have a high
rank in a social group what it means is
that you can relax because the people
beneath you in the hierarchy are
screwing around busily making sure that
you're never unhappy and never
displeased so the really high ranking
person can be totally relaxed not in a
rush the high ranking person by the way
also owns and controls time so when you
have rank you can use time any way you
like including having your sentences
come out when you're ready to complete
them right that's how a high ranking
person uses time and it's people who are
speaking quickly are signaling that they
don't feel entitled to take the group's
time with their words this great
sweeping gestures things a bit
theatrical so you're probably not going
to use that very often in the places
where you work but I think what it
conveys is something equally important
which is that when playing high you not
only control time you control space so a
high-ranking person decides where the
physical boundaries are between the
things that belong to them that things
that belong to other people and
high-ranking people have permission to
violate physical and space boundaries in
ways that that lower ranking people
don't when walking and playing high you
assume others will get out of your path
so we that's consistent with what we saw
in the person moving forward without
hesitation you don't check other's eyes
for approval or in reaction for reaction
to anything you've said and you have no
visible reaction to what others say
either you can interrupt before you know
what you're going to say spread your
body to full comfort and
look down by tilting your head back a
bit so this is something you can try
wherever you're sitting right now it's
actually a very very powerful adjustment
if you lift your chin a little you'll
notice that you're looking down out of
the bottom of your eyes are actually
looking down your nose and you can feel
when you do it it's kind of a snooty
attitude that you've adopted so one of
the things I've seen in a lot of the
coaching that we do in the classroom is
that when someone's trying to deliver
remarks with gravitas and can't quite
get there after several tries the the
director the acting coach will come
behind them and actually physically lift
their chin like this and say say the
line now and it has a hugely
transformative effect for the opposite
just to show you right when you have
your head up and you're looking down on
at the bottom of your eyes it's a little
bit of a superior attitude when you tilt
your chin down and look up on at the top
of your eyes it's you know like this is
how my kids look at me when they know
they're in trouble
conveys something completely different
how imply playing hi you can talk
matter-of-factly about things others
find offensive you can speak cryptically
with no explanation and what you're
trying to do in general is to convey the
message to come near me I bite so this
is the picture that I've always used to
remind myself of what it looks like to
play hi and what I love about this is
you can see the expanse of expansiveness
way that she's holding her body you can
see how the costume actually helps with
the footprint issue right so she's
taking up actually a lot more space than
her physical body would and the total
absence of facial expression is another
really interesting aspect of playing hi
then I'm going to talk about in just a
moment we had a bunch of questions that
came in then several people have now
asked about how to play high in virtual
meetings yeah so this is the question
that we get a lot and and the thing
that's important to recognize we if you
think back to that slide I showed you
the pie chart with the words accounting
for less than 10% so what this tells you
is you've got to find a way in the
virtual
to use the rest of it the physical
gestures obviously if people can't see
you have less impact although they're
going to have impact on the way you show
up psychologically how you feel in the
way you participate that's another story
but I think where you can really focus
in virtual context is by looking at some
of these other some of these other
behaviors I just listed so things like
how quickly you speak how quickly you
respond to other people the way that you
respond to other people and one of the
things I haven't talked about that turns
out to be very important and it's
related to some of the other things that
I've told you already is that the
picture of your voice actually has a big
impact so lower pitch is associated with
higher rank and higher status and there
are also physical reasons for this if
you think about this notion of opening
and relaxing your body which is what
comes naturally with rank but something
you may want to work work on yourself
whatwhat opening your body and relaxing
your body allows you to do is to have a
clear pathway from your diaphragm to
your to your throat and your and your
and your mouth right so the voice
actually originates in your diaphragm
and actually here might pitch going down
and I'm talking about this when you're
fully relaxed your your voice can come
from a lower place located in a lower
spot in your body and what happens
naturally when we experience stress and
anxiety and the body constricts is that
the tension is heard in our voice the
pitch gets higher and you start to hear
the voice as though it's coming from the
head and the sinus and the throat area
and for this reason we tend to associate
higher pitched voices with lower status
and lower pitched voices with higher
status so that's something else you can
work within a virtual in a virtual
meeting setting let me talk to you a
little bit about the behaviors
associated with playing low and we're
going to talk more in just a minute
about why these are good for you to be
able to do so it before you check out
and do something else
listing the the behavior associate was
playing well let's take a look at what
they are so in playing low again this
comes from the theater the way you use
your body is completely different you
make fleeting and jerky movements so
here's the idea that we talked about
earlier where it's almost like your
different parts of your body have
different intentions and different
objectives right they're moving
independent of one another and sometimes
getting and nuts in one another's way
you keep your hands near your face while
speaking it's almost like you're trying
to hide you're not sure you should
really really be there and be seeing
what you have to say you glance around a
lot and look away so on the eye
contacting a low ranking person
addressing a high ranking person will
never look them directly in the eye it's
too much of an affront on their physical
boundaries
so what you'll tend to see in a low
ranking person is even if they're
addressing you they'll be looking other
places and just glancing that could do
to make sure that everything is going
okay on the other hand when the low
ranking person is being addressed by a
high ranking person that's where you see
their eyes riveted on the person who is
sending information down to the chain of
command you also point your toes inward
and lean forward when playing low again
these are ways of making your footprint
smaller speak in in complete sentences
smile with teeth covering bottom lips
show top teeth only this is also a
fairly technical theater note but let me
talk to you about what this means so I
talked earlier about the absence of
facial expression in the Judi Dench
character that I had on the screen a
moment ago and playing high smiling it
turns out has very important meaning in
the social science of understanding
power and Status if you compare the
natural behavior of low ranking group
members and high ranking group members
one of the most obvious differences you
observe is that the lower ranking
members smile more and it's not because
life is better at the bottom right what
the smiles are doing is attempting to
appease higher rank
group members the job of a low-ranking
member the role description of a
low-ranking member is to make sure that
high-ranking people are never ever
uncomfortable so what this means is you
get a lot of smiles that are not genuine
right they're apologetic smiles they're
uncomfortable and embarrassed smiles and
this one smiling with your teeth
covering your bottom lip and showing
your toffee to something like this which
is again one of these apologetic type of
things you hesitate with er or um before
your sentence sound breathless seem like
an intruder apologize for being there
take up as little space as possible so
space constrains your body and you can
use what's called a cherub posture which
is the opposite of what I showed you
earlier in the highly masculine version
which is that whenever you hold your
body in a way that shows points of
physical vulnerability that makes you
physically off-balance so tilting your
head to the side is one of the ways that
we do this facing someone indirectly is
another way that we do this and then
standing with our weight on one leg like
this as opposed to with our weight
evenly distributed on two legs these are
all part of the chair of posture and
what your signal when you do this is
that you're vulnerable that you're not
going to you're not showing up as a
fortress rather that you'll be easy to
easy to move when walking and playing
low you move out of others paths you
briefly check others eyes looking for
approval and you speak haltingly edit as
you go and trail off something I should
mention about this too that may may be
on your mind so knowing that we use
email a lot people will often ask you
know how does this show up in email and
what if your most important interactions
are happening that way very easy to see
how these differences show up in email
as well the speed of responding is one
thing but even if you think about the
notion of speaking cryptically with no
explanation as opposed to explaining
yourself you know you can see very
easily how emails from low to high
ranking members differ from those that
come generate from a higher higher rank
in the organization the lower ranking
person will tend to ramble and say much
more than is necessary in an email
because they have to provide all the
context and make sure there's no chance
any way that they've offended anyone
with what they've said and the high
ranking person often says less than is
necessary actually it doesn't have the
time and figures you will take the
initiative and figure it out you make
yourself physically uncomfortable to
give the other person's space I should
talk about this too for just a moment
because it's something that's going to
come up later one of my colleagues in
the classroom
a guy named Dan Klein who also teaches
at Stanford does a lot of work on status
in improv he's actually an actor an
improvisational artist himself talks
about how people with different level of
status use furniture and what he loves
to say is that high status people use
furniture wrong so you can sort of see
how it should play itself out by this
idea of making yourself physically
uncomfortable to give someone else pay
so a low-ranking person will sit in the
chair and make themselves as small as
possible and you know use only the
amount of space they've been allowed
allotted where a high-ranking person
will often sit with their body in one
chair and their arm across the second
chair or they'll put their feet on the
desk or they'll sit on your desk or the
lie on the couch but whatever they do
what I need to do to make themselves
comfortable but as a consequence what
you're seeing also is that there's no
regard for the comfort level of anyone
else it's really about the comfort of
the self and the low ranking person does
the opposite all the physical movements
are about making other people feel more
comfortable we talked about the angle of
the head so looking up at the other
person by tilting your head down as part
of playing low and shouting an attempt
to intimidate this is also not intuitive
let me say a word about it or - one of
the things you see a lot in the coaching
that I do in the classroom is that when
people are in a scene and having a
confrontation and trying to dot you know
out play hi one another out dominate one
another is they'll start to raise their
voices and shout
and if somebody soon as somebody shouts
what the audience says right away is you
lost your power as soon as you did that
and it's very interesting about why
that's true so the coach is in a
situation like that will often say them
look the the best thing to do to
maintain power in a situation where
you're having this type of confrontation
is to go completely silent
have no reaction at all to someone
shouting in your face and then they'll
sometimes say now whisper your next line
and all the power comes the quiet person
because what's shouting indicates is
that the stakes are higher for you right
the stakes are higher for the person
who's unravelling then for the person
who's able to maintain control in a
situation like that so this requires a
tremendous amount of discipline but I
think very important for us to
understand that all of the angry kinds
of motions that we tend to think of as
showing power or attempts to intimidate
people tend to come out because we're
feeling like we're losing and people are
aware of this as well when playing low
you crouch or protect your body in
whatever way you can or your face as if
to ward off a blow adjust what you're
saying to make others understand explain
yourself and you're sending the general
message please don't bite me I'm not
worth it so this is my favorite low
player and pretty much any Woody Allen
film you'll see him doing doing the same
thing for their other questions at this
point
yeah a lot of questions actually so a
bunch of people have asked about how
what do you play with your boss's boss
and so slow right and so that's sort of
what it was coming across and so we're
saying is that some of the traits that
you're showing for low seem to make
people not approachable but seem to get
them look very weak yes so well there's
there's two aspects of that there's a
weakness aspect and there's the
unapproachable 'ti aspect of it so I'm
glad that question came up this is
actually really important both the
behaviors associated with playing high
and the behavior associates playing low
can come from a place of
here which is not good right it's like
shouting an attempt to intimidate it's
like hiding and trying to get away or
they can come from a place of love which
is which is a place where what you're
trying to do is connect with the other
person so you can play hi from a
generous place you're providing security
you're providing cover you're including
people in your circle and you can play
low from a place of generosity as well
which is to say I'm here I support you I
respect you and I'm ready to do whatever
is required of me given my rank so
that's a very very important distinction
remember that the actions are not
prescriptive but rather descriptions of
what you tend to see people doing and a
lot of times when people have low rank
low rank the natural feeling is is fear
and wanting to hide but to the extent
that you can get yourself to a place
where you recognize that being low rank
is a source of power and if the higher
ranking people actually need you in
order to maintain their position you can
come at that from a much more generous
place which i think is much more
effective just to clarify because we had
a lot of questions about this yes so
when you want to look very confident to
your boss's boss you're playing low but
you're you're coming with you're feeling
confidence is that what you're saying
what sort of body postures and what do
you do to make sure that you're playing
low and appear in confidence yeah yeah
so well like I said before it's
difficult to do these things in the same
at the same time the same moment so what
you'll typically see in people I think
most of you do this already is there's a
constant up and down this to the way we
interact with people right and when
you're giving a presentation or having a
meeting or an encounter with your boss's
boss there'll be a lot of up and down to
that there'll be moments where your
natural instinct I hope will be to show
that you know actually how you rank
relatives this person because they need
that for their security right that's a
way of showing appropriate respect but
there will be moments where you can
sense from them if they're looking to
see who you are and what you know
that's where you can step into things
with confidence so it tends to be an
up-and-down to this and a lot of times
the authoritative nough sit will happen
in a blink it will happen in a flash and
then with a very high-ranking person
we'll check in from a lower place to
make sure that it's going to cross
effectively so that's one way of
thinking about it the other way to think
about this and the boss is boss again
this is a tricky one I mean I I am you
know I am one who is much more confident
in the power of the ability to be
deferential and respectful and many
people are but the advice that we tend
to give people in situations that are
that are complicated or uncertain is to
play just slightly under the person
you're interacting with now this is
typically advice that you would give to
someone where the status relationship is
unknown or appear and the idea is that
what you're doing is you take the cues
off the other person the level at which
they want to be interacting and you can
match that almost so you want to be
playing high enough to be taken
seriously but never a threat so that
type of strategy is going to be most
effective when there's not a large
distance between you and other people I
think when there is a large distance
it's much much safer to start from from
a place of genuine respect which is to
say you can show what you know and and
and what you do and become it in that
but you're always doing it with
deference to somebody who has higher
rank and who has the right to judge you
right they have a right to judge you on
that
you don't have a right to judge them in
those interactions in the same way
hopefully that's helped them clearing
that up but it's um it's subtle it's
very subtle I would say okay I'm getting
indication to that time let me take one
more question that I'll go forward a lot
of people are very interested in the how
this cuts across culture yes so I'm
almost there I mean let me jump to the
culture question I've started to answer
the questions I think is really where
most of you are at this point which is
how do you think about using this
knowledge I am NOT suggesting and I hope
this has come across that you get ahead
in life by playing high in all
situations
have to remind people of that when they
first see this information really what
I'm talking about is to is about the
ability to recognize that hierarchy is a
critical determinant of how you should
behave in a particular situation to know
how to read a hierarchy based on how
other people are behaving and then to
know how to tune your behavior to
circumstances that you encounter
especially when there's a challenge so I
suspect in most situations and this is
true for me I don't think about this at
all right I trust them consciously I'm
responding in ways that make sense when
I'm going into a new situation where I'm
going into a situation where there's a
relationship challenge that's where I
start to think more strategically about
what I can do with myself physically to
make a relationship work better so how
did you think about using this knowledge
one of the most important things I want
to convey and I think I just said it in
a lower level of detail is that the only
surefire the only certain way to attain
status and power that lasts is to
repeatedly do what's best for the group
so what that means is whenever you're
thinking about using these things you
have to be taken into account what I
just described for you this is not about
you and your ability to to play higher
than the people around you this is about
you and your ability to understand that
groups need hierarchy to function right
there's a reason situations are always
hierarchical even though we don't want
them to be even though we say we prefer
equality to hierarchy situations are
always hierarchical because groups need
hierarchy so the best thing you can do
for your group is to act in a way that
takes hierarchy into account a lot of
times this means you stick to the role
prescription associated with your rank
sometimes it means you step out of rank
I'm going to talk about that in just a
minute but really the most important
thing to recognize is that these tactics
and strategies really only have an
effective impact in a long-lasting way
if you're taking into account what's
best for the group I was working with a
group of leaders recently we had a
conversation about this and
there was a Japanese executive who
understood this because I think in Japan
making very differently about groups and
Harken and we do in the US and what she
said I thought was very apt which is
that playing low is how you earn the
right to claim status and leadership in
a group right these things are not
incompatible when a person tries to step
into a leadership vacuum or step into a
high status position without having
built the trust of the group without
having shown over and over again that
they know their plays that they
understand the importance of the
hierarchy those attempts are much less
likely to be effective and I agree with
that I think that's exactly how I think
about it so what this implies is that
you're most likely to be effective using
the actions associated playing high when
you do this to reinforce your actual
position so that people aren't confused
and you can think of that as an act of
generosity right our circumstances in
which the group needs to know you're in
charge the group needs to know that
you've got it so you want to make sure
your body language is lined up with the
things that you're saying in situations
like that
what authoritative this is called for
obviously playing high or higher than
usual is useful and you can use the
actions associate playing high to claim
status in a competitive situation also
when it's up for grabs I want to let
people know that in terms of playing
above rank you'd be very careful about
this the easiest way to get in trouble
in a group is to act in a way that
thinks you're higher that shows you
think you're higher than you actually
are and this is true across cultures but
let me just quickly speak to the culture
institution just came up and I'm going
to have to wrap up into a couple of
minutes here one of the things you need
to know about thinking about playing
above your rank is what's best for the
group given the culture that you're in
in some cultures there's a lot more
latitude around showing respect and
enacting above your rank than others let
me just say a couple words about this if
you see this slide here what you're
looking at are ratings with people from
various cultures around the world on a
dimension that's related to what we're
talking about which is called power
distance their cultures that that rate
short very high on power distance
there's a large power distance in
cultures that slope with a smaller power
distance you can see the u.s. is on the
lower power distance or smaller power
distance I'd and a lot of the Asian
cultures tend to be on higher power
distance power distance refers to the
event to which the hierarchy is is the
the most critical aspect of social
relationships in a group it's a
reflection of the extent to which people
treat the hierarchy as though it's given
from God as opposed to you know what we
do in the u.s. such as we get there's
hierarchy we use hierarchy but there are
places in which really it's okay not to
take it too seriously and I think
Silicon Valley is a great example where
you have college dropouts with no job
experience you know asking a venture
capitalist to give them millions of
dollars to to run ventures right that's
actually ok here there are many parts of
the world in which that would never fly
so let me just say that quickly about
culture and if there's time we can come
back to the other dimension on this on
this on this chart the implications for
playing low are basically the same
you play low for a place of generosity
to reinforce your actual position to
show respect and give security to people
above you when deference is called for
it's important for building rapport you
can do it to lift someone else up I
would say one of the most important
things I've learned from doing research
in this area but also the teaching that
I do is that the ability to play under
rank is one of the most critical skills
of an effective leader and a manager
this is what people tell me over and
over again after they leave my quarters
and go back into the world understanding
how to effectively show up lower than
rank and understanding that that's an
effective tactic has been one of the
most useful things they took away we
know that playing low makes high status
actors more approachable we talked about
this as well let me leave you with one
final thing so I'm just going to do a
quick a quick demonstration I mentioned
earlier how ways of using your body can
affect how you actually feel and I want
to try to do a very quick demonstration
if I can so I'm going to ask you at home
were at work wherever you are to get
into an expansive posture so most of you
have probably been wanting to do this if
you haven't already make sure your arms
and legs are far away from one another
and far away from your body
and hold that posture don't get out of
it so make sure you're all spread out
while you're in the posture I'm just
going to ask you to read the next three
sentences that come up on the screen and
just reflect on how that feels okay go
ahead
so most people report in that situations
that they don't actually believe a word
of what they're saying and it's not the
case that we never feel this way but
you'll notice how your body makes it
difficult to get into the mindset of the
words you're trying to use let's do the
opposite get into a constricted posture
right now so arms and legs close
together close to the body you can put
your hands between your knees or sit on
them hold that posture and while you're
holding it read these next three
sentences should have the same type of
ironic effect on your behavior and what
we know from research just to say this
quickly is that if you ask people to get
into advances versus constricted
postures for just two minutes it affects
their tolerance for risk so people on an
expansive posture are more likely to
gamble people of constricted posture are
more likely to be conserve and play it
safe and we also know that these
different postures are associated with
hormone shades so people who sit
expansively tend to have increased
testosterone as a result and people who
sit constructively tend to have
increased cortisol which is a hormone
associated with stress and
stress-related illnesses so the left
message I want to leave you with is when
thinking about situations where you want
to have impact much less about what you
say much more about how you say it and
thanks for your attention